All right, so let's do a brief aside about the
[LAUGH], this is like a bad history of reinforcement learning so
it's not that it's a bad history, it's just badly
told. So but the basic idea is this, once upon a
time and we're going to call it, say the 1930s people
observed. That if you put an animal, this is supposed to
be a rat, in, in a, you know, box, say. And
give it choices of looking in place B and place A
and, say, one of them has cheese in it and the other one
doesn't, but it can't see which because, you know, the doors are closed.
And and let's say that we, we consistently do something like this. We
turn on a red light whenever the cheese is in the A place. And
we turn on a blue light whenever the cheese is in the, B
place. And what you observe is if you do this consistently, then what you
find is that if the animal sees the stimulus like the red light
going on and it takes an action like peeking inside the, the or sticking
it's head inside the box A and it gets
a reward which in this case would be getting
to eat some cheese. That that set up strengthens
its response to the stimulus. In other words, in the
future when it sees the red light it's going to
be more likely to go in and look in box
A. And this notion of strengthening, you can think
of it as reinforcing the connection. Reinforcing just means strengthening.
>> Hm.
>> So, this was studied for a long time and there's,
there's tremendous amount of interesting research
about this, but if you start to,
you know, think about it as a computer scientist. A natural way of, of
kind of thinking about what this problem is, is that you know, a
stimulus is kind of like a state, and an action is kind of like
an action, and a reward, well, I kind of stole all these words
but it's kind of like a reward. And it leads you to this idea
that what you really want to do. Is figure out how to choose
actions to maximize reward as a function of the state. And so we started
to take this concept and we called it reinforcement learning because that's what
the psychologists were calling it. But,
for us it just means reward maximization.
This notion of strengthening is really not part of the story for us
at all. So, we're really taking this word and using it, you know, wrong.
>> Hm. Well, that all makes sense except
for one thing, which is the idea that this
happened in the 1930s. Because we all know
that rat dinosaurs did not exist in the 1930s.
>> Yeah, they, well they went extinct in the 40s.
>> Hm, hm.
>> There's this one little epilogue to the story which I find really kind of
amusing, and that is the computer scientists did
pretty well at figuring out algorithms for solving
problems like this. And the psychologists really do
care about how stimuli and, and, motor actions
and reward all Interact with each other and
they've turned to the computer scientists to say,
how might the brain be doing this? What, what is the problem that
the brain actually might be solving? And
so, guess what word [LAUGH] they borrowed
back when they started to think about these things. Reinforcement. So, now they
talk about reinforcement learning and they don't
mean reinforcement, either. They mean reward maximization.
>> So we won.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I do not think that was really our plan but
but it's, it's nice to know that we had some you know, impact.
>> Well, that's very
good you brought planning back into it and so
they learned because of our plan, that's pretty good Michael.
>> [LAUGH] All right, so that's the end of this aside.
>> Okay.
>> Let's go, let's go, let's go back to learning things.